avec wohlen frappe bonjour hélène
bonjour pauline et on revient hélène
tout de suite sur l'accord de principe
conclu à l'instant habemus accord un
fumée blanche bout de la nuit entre la
france insoumise et le parti socialiste
en vue des législatives du mois de juin
fumée blanche ou plutôt fumée rouge rose
et verte après les écologistes et le
parti communiste jean luc mélenchon
semble en effet avoir remporté son pari
en parvenant à s'entendre aussi avec les
socialistes l'humanité qui avait mis
sous presse avant cette annonce évoqué
déjà hier soir un accord historique s'il
venait à se concrétiser c'est chose
faite donc un accord présenté comme le
fruit de l'exigence du peuple de gauche
qui se serait puissamment exprimées en
faveur de cette union sans cette amicale
pression sans cette aspiration massive
l'alliance n'auraient probablement pas
vu le jour salue lui m'a soulagé de voir
la gauche française ont monté si vite
sur le ring après sa brutale élimination
de la course à la présidentielle amicale
pression pas sûr que tout le monde voit
les choses de la même façon on y
reviendra dans le journal de 9h30 à la
une également hélène bien sûr les
réactions au projet encore en discussion
là pour le coup de la cour suprême
américaine d'annuler l'arrêt qui avaient
ou d'écraser l'arrêt qui avait accordé
le droit à l'avortement dans le pays
c'est en 1973 dans le sillage de joe
biden qui a appelé on cesse ses
compatriotes à défendre ce droit à
l'avortement dans les urnes lors des
élections de mi mandat en novembre
prochain le dessinateur pat burns accuse
la cour suprême de ne pas vouloir
s'arrêter là ce n'est pas une décision
finale il y à d'autres droits que nous
aimerions annulée faite il ya un juge
cette inquiétude est partagée par adam
cycliste qui montre la barque de la
liberté des droits des femmes prendre
l'eau sur le point de couler bob ingrate
lui s'indigne de voir les juges menace
c'est le droit des femmes à disposer
librement de leur corps avec ce dessin
où l'on voit un utérus devenu propriété
de la cour suprême des etats unis
la presse conservatrice américaine
accuse de son côté les démocrates de
chercher à instrumentaliser
cette question de l'accès à l'ivg et
j'ai mal au wall street journal estime
que les fuites sur les discussions au
sein de la cour suprême constitue un
acte de malveillance face auquel les
juges ne devrait pas se laisser
intimider
renversé rhône ne serait pas la fin de
l'avortement en amérique mais renverrait
simplement cette affaire ce droit aux
affaires des états qui seront libres de
restreindre d'interdire ou de faciliter
le droit à l'avortement tempère le
journal le washington times lui pauline
tente également de minimiser la portée
d'une éventuelle remise en cause de
l'arrêt de 73 en assurant que le nombre
d'avortements aux etats-unis et de toute
façon à un niveau historiquement bas
autrement dit beaucoup de bruit pour
rien de la part des démocrates beaucoup
bien sûr donc de réactions dans la
presse américaine et également de ce
côté ci de l'atlantique dans la presse
européenne à deux gardiennes quotidien
britannique évoque le sombre
aboutissement d'une croisade menée par
des fanatiques je cite contre la volonté
de la majorité une menace pour la santé
le bonheur et la vie des femmes
favoriser selon lui par l'héritage
juridique de donald trump en allemagne
le frankfurter allgemeine zeitung
dénonce un combat culturel mené sur le
dos des femmes enfin en france
libération cite simone veil qui avait on
s'en souvient porté la loi encadrant la
dépénalisation de l'avortement adoptés
en france en
1974 un an après ce fameux arrêt rovers
wade à l'époque la ministre a récité la
grande féministe française simone de
beauvoir comme vous m'avez si
pertinemment rappelé n'oubliez jamais
qu'il suffira d'une crise politique
économique aux religieuses pour que les
droits des femmes soient remises en
question libé appelle à défendre le
droit des femmes à l'avortement aux
états unis mais partout ailleurs dans le
monde y compris en europe où l'on
empêche actuellement les ukrainiennes
victimes de viols d'avoir accès à l'ivg
en pologne et libé avait bien raison
effectivement entités citées ces propos
de simone de beauvoir à la une également
hélène sur un autre sujet les élections
générales ce sera lundi prochain aux
philippines où ferdinand marcos junior
est donné largement favori à la
présidentielle il est bien connu définit
pas en tout cas ce son père un domaine
et notamment annonce même la victoire
inévitable du sis de l'ancien dictateur
ferdinand marcos face à l'actuelle
vice-présidente lainiers robredo le
financial times parle de l'élection la
plus importante aux philippines depuis
qu'un soulèvement populaire avait
renversé ferdinand marcos et restaurer
la démocratie en 1986 d'après le
quotidien britannique le dictateur déchu
n'est évidemment pas sur les bulletins
de vote mais son héritage se perpétue à
travers son fils qui se présente avec la
promesse de restaurer l'âge d'or du
règne de son père un récit qui serait
parvenu à s'imposer auprès de la jeune
génération des philippins qui n'ont pas
connu les remarques hausse dont le fils
est par ailleurs activement soutenu par
le président sortant rodrigo doute arte
qui s'est surtout active et raymond le
sait au cours de son mandat à museler la
dissidence réprimer les droits et
déclenché une guerre contre la drogue
qui a fait des milliers de morts
ce quitte là dessus on se quitte là
dessus mais c'est comme ça on n'est pas
là pour rigoler aujourd'hui merci
beaucoup hélène c'était la revue de
presse